. Hey, herzlich willkommen zu das Podcast U, mit Florentin DPW, ja und als kleine Überraschung heute bei uns im Studio, er sitzt hier, es ist Stefan Tietze, Stefan T und Florentin W, ja wir sind da, herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe. Das Podcast U. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Vielen, vielen Dank an dieses tolle Intro von Dennis mit zwei N und einem D. Vielen Dank für diesen kleinen Ausflug in die Vergangenheit oder Zukunft. Das weiß man ja oft gar nicht. Nee, waren das die Achtziger? Man weiß es nicht. Die Dinge kommen immer wieder. Es ist gleichzeitig Nostalgie und Sehnsucht in die Zukunft. Das ist das Tolle an der Kunst von Dennis. Das macht er gut, da verbindet er beide Welten in einem musikalischen Wenn-Diagramm. Danke Dennis, die beiden Ns hast du dir redlich verdient. Gehörig verdient. Gehörig verdient. Denn, die wir seit Folge 201 wissen, das N ist der, habe ich ja vergessen, ich glaube der dritt, der zweit wichtigste Buchstabe. Wäre es denn unmöglich, sein Kind Dennis mit drei N zu nennen? Ich glaube nicht. Eigentlich nicht, es spricht ja nichts dagegen. Ich glaube, du darfst nur dein Kind, es muss, glaube ich, ich glaube, es gibt ein paar Regeln für Namen, aber es spricht nichts dagegen, einfach zu sagen Dennis mit drei N. Und da kommen wir gleich zum Thema der Folge, lass uns die Grenzen weiterschieben. Let's push the boundaries. Lass uns die Grenzen ausreizen. Die Scheuklappen ablegen, die Handbremse lösen. Ich fühle mich hierzu eingeengt. Ich will mich wegdrängen. Woher willst du denn hin? Die Grenzen sollen weg von mir. Ich fühle mich wie Star Wars 4 in der Milchpresse, aber lass uns mal die Grenzen wegpushen. Okay, aber du bist nicht eingeengt von konkreten Dingen, sondern eher von dem Konzept der Grenze im Allgemeinen.
Zwei Ends sind die Grenzen wegpushen. Okay, aber du bist nicht eingeengt von konkreten Dingen, sondern eher von dem Konzept der Grenze im Allgemeinen. Zwei N's sind die Grenze für Denisse. Ja, ich will weg davon. Gib mir zwei N's und vier I's. Ja. Und dann viel Spaß, mein Junge, mit dem Leben, dass du immer sagst. Mit dem Namen. Ja, ich heisse Dennis mit drei N's und vier I's und 36 S. Ich kann es Ihnen buchstabieren. Das ist ganz schrecklich. Ganz, ganz schrecklich. Aber jetzt ist die Frage, macht ein ein furchtbarer Name nicht zu einem besseren Menschen? Tja, das ist die Frage. Wird man nicht gepresst? Ich kann aus eigener Hand, aus eigenem Erlebnis erzählen. Du heisst Florentin, du heisst nicht Florentin. Naja, es ist kein schrecklicher Name, aber aussergewöhnlich, man wird natürlich oft anders angesprochen. Ich weiß gar nicht, was es für einen Effekt hat, wenn der Name immer falsch ausgesprochen wird. Wahrscheinlich viele Leute können sich damit identifizieren, die einen Namen haben, der nicht so direkt gängig ist, da wo man wohnt. Es erdet ein bisschen, es erdet ein bisschen und vor allem, ich glaube, die ersten drei Male korrigiert man noch, wenn man Florian genannt wird, aber irgendwann nicht mehr.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist auch ein bisschen wie so ein Spam-Filter, weil du direkt mitbekommst, ob ein Idiot vor dir steht, slash Idiotin. Weil wenn jemand dich kontinuierlich Florian nennt, da kann man auch irgendwann sagen, okay, du bist kein Mensch, mit dem ich jetzt mehr interagieren möchte. Vor allem wenn es jemand ist, der mich schon mal Florentin genannt hat. Also der aus irgendeinem Grundrückschritt zurückgerudert ist von richtig zu falsch, was eine merkwürdige Entwicklung ist. Normalerweise ist es andersrum, aber da war es falsch. Aber das Tolle ist, weil mittlerweile, wenn mich jemand Florian merkt, sage ich nichts, ich nehme das an, danke, lasse mir nichts anmerken und denke mir, du wirst dich irgendwann noch entschuldigen. Hörst du auf Florian? Ich höre auf Florian. Nee, wie so ein Hund. Also hörst du auf Florian, wenn man driss dich um auf der Strasse, wenn ich rufe Florian. Ja, wie so ein Hund, ich reagiere auf alles, wenn es mit der richtigen Emotion gesprochen wird. Jemand sagt, Rudolf, will ich auch sofort dabei nicht mehr, oh. Der hört auf Florian und Rudolf. Ich höre auf alles, ich höre auf alles. Ich muss natürlich daran denken, weil Nils Bokelberg zum Beispiel, der mit Z geschrieben wird. Ach, wirklich offiziell, vom Amt Das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, das ist ein Künstlername. Und du, Florentin? Und auch wenn ihr dann Anfragen bekommt von der Presse. Und ich habe immer das Gefühl, manchmal sind die nicht so toll recherchiert. Und wenn die dann, hallo Florian, vielleicht hättest du Interesse für diesen folgenden Moderationsjob, weiss man auch direkt, Vollidioten. Da werde ich nicht drauf antworten, nicht drauf eingehen. Ich glaube, das hilft direkt
den Menschen einzuordnen. Ich habe dann auch
noch diesen ulkigen
Nachnamen, der
verrückterweise auch ein Verb ist, also das ist ja
völlig, ich weiß nicht, was
das für eine Idee war, ganz verrückt,
ein Ulk, also wirklich ein Ulk,
der aber teilweise auch anders
falsch verstanden wird, wo es dann hieß, bei
einem Interview mal so, ist es Will oder Willnorek?
Willnorek? What? Aber ich musste gerade daran denken, weil ich dich manchmal Willnorek nenne. Ja, vielleicht kommt das sogar daher, dass du mich mal als Gag, als Florentin Willnorek vorgestellt hast. Du bist die eine Folge, die alle immer zur Recherche anhören. Ja genau, es ist immer Folge 100, wo genau die Leute gucken. Und dann dachte ich mir, in welcher Welt leben diese Menschen, die denken, ich würde meinen Nachnamen abkürzen? Mehr. Niemand hat einen Spitznamen für seinen Nachnamen. Doch, Louis C.K. Okay, C.K., gut, aber da hast du vielleicht die Abkürzung. Da ist klar, dass es nicht der echte Nachname ist. Aber die Idee, dass jemand, der Vilnorek heißt, sich abkürzt mit Will, ist also grandios. Und nicht Willno. Vor allem, ich denke mir, in welcher Welt lebt dieser Mensch, für den es völlig selbstverständlich ist, nachzufragen. Weil wenn jetzt jemand Ricky heisst oder so, dass man heisst, heisst du Richard oder Ricky oder also so. Aber Wilnorek ist ja ein anderer Name. Ist ein anderer Name, einfach, dass man den Nachnamen auch abfragen muss. Tizzer oder Tizkowski? Tizzerritzi. Ach, ist das kurz für Tizzerritzki, okay, verstehe. Ich glaube, es kommt wirklich, und jetzt müssen wir mal nachforschen eigentlich, ich glaube, das kommt von der Puffopedia. Ja, weil ich dich mal Wilnore, getauft habe. Das kann sein. Und im Internet, das glaube ich, kurz für Willnorek oder sowas. Ich glaube, diese ganzen Namensgags werden uns noch lange verfolgen, wenn Leute in irgendwelchen Zeitungsartikeln oder nachrufen. Wir können eine seriöse Karriere ab diesem Zeitpunkt komplett vergessen. Nee, absolut vergessen. Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, ich denke mir oft so, was ist, wenn ich in die Politik gehe? Weil wir haben ja alle so Tagtraumomente, wo man sagt, krass mal irgendeinen Verbrecher aufhalten oder was ist, wenn ich wirklich gewählt werden würde. Politik ist völliger Unsinn, völliger Nonsinn. Ich stelle mir das dann ganz leicht vor, so ich denke mir, wir machen dann so, also ich sage dann einfach, wie das passieren soll und das passiert dann so, so jeder kriegt 20 Euro oder so und kann dann entscheiden, was damit passiert und solche Fantasieobjekte, wo jemand, der sich mit Politik auskennt, sagt, ja, aber das ist doch aus dem Grund falsch. Das ist doch das. Und du sagst, ach so. Das ist doch hier Fremdwörteinfügen. Und jemand sagt, naja, aber das sind doch Steuern. Ach ja, stimmt, meine grandiose Idee, wie man dem Staat Geld verschaffen könnte, war, die gibt's schon. Okay, ja, das ist ... Nee, aber auch wenn ich so denke, jetzt was selbst bei Politikern, die nicht wirklich was verbrochen haben, rausgekramt wird, um die öffentlich zu verleumden, das halten wir ja in tausendfacher Potenz, weil wenn wir beides kandidieren würden, da haben die fast 250 Folgen, wo in jeder Folge etwas drin ist, warum wir öffentlich nicht Politik führen sollen. Auf der anderen Seite, ich glaube, das könnte das Tutanich-Amun-Prinzip sein. Das Tutanich-Amun-Prinzip ist ja, dass die haben ja eine riesige Pyramide gebaut, mit einem toten König drin und mit ganz vielen Schätzen drin, weil der muss ja in der Nachwelt, wenn der dann in der Nachwelt aufwacht, dann hat er zwar kein Gehirn mehr, doch der hat das Gehirn in so einer Schale daneben und kann dann sagen, oh danke, dass er mir mein Gehirn rausgenommen hat, er zieht es wieder rein, niemand weiß, wie das genau funktioniert. Sterben die Schätze mit ihm? Eigentlich nicht, weil die sollen ja in der Nachwelt noch da sein, du wirst ja mit deinem ganzen Hab und Gut begraben. Also Gegenstände können einfach in die Nachwelt gebiegelt werden. Das ist so das Ding, aber was für eine enorme Verschwendung auch, oder? Also ich meine, so in Europa halt so mit Vererbung, ja, ich lebe dann halt in der Burg und ich kriege die Schwer. Ja, aber jetzt sag mal, Ägyptern zahlt mal Steuern, wenn die literally alles an Reichtum, deswegen ist glaube ich Ägypten da runtergegangen, weil die einfach ihr Reichtum dem Toten gegeben haben, in das Grab mit reingeschmissen haben.
Ja.
Was eine dusselige Idee. Jetzt verklickern mal dem ägyptischen Volk, nee, wir brauchen Steuern, damit der Staat weiter existieren kann. Und alle gucken so, die Schulter zucken zur Pyramide, wo alles, wofür wir gearbeitet haben, drin ist. Vor allem, ich meine, wir blicken ja heute zurück und sagen, antikes Ägypten, das hat so eine mythische Qualität, aber natürlich gab es da auch eine Art Markus Lanz, der irgendwie dann mit dem Pharao in der Talkshow oder halt auf dem Marktplatz saß und kritische Fragen gestellt hat und gesagt hat, unser Staatshaushalt ist fast bankrott, der Nil kam nur zwei Meter dieses Jahr hoch, wir sind stark verschuldet, wir haben enorme Goldschätze in diesem riesigen Steinturm. Und der Pfarrer sagt, ja gut, aber das ist ja mein Vater, also da können wir nicht einfach rein und das holen. Da gibt es immer einen in der Talkshow, der sagt, und warum gehen wir so? Warum gehen wir so? Das hat der Wolfgang Kubicki. Jetzt versuchen Sie aber gerade nicht vom Thema abzudenken. Das Thema ist gerade, warum nicht die Pyramide aufknacken. Da sind zehn Milliarden Gulden wert an Goldschätzen, die unseren Staatshaushalt in einer Sekunde wieder in grünen Zahlen bringen können, in schwarzen Zahlen, warum auch immer. Da gibt es einen monothematischen Menschen, der immer sagt, ja, ich sag nur, wenn wir anders gehen würden, würden wir vielleicht doch eher zur Pyramide gehen, um da das Gold wieder rauszuholen.
Ich sage, wenn wir einer das gehen würde... Ja, wir können auch vielleicht was anderes als Vögel als Schrift benutzen.
Wir haben viele Probleme. Wir lösen eins nach dem anderen.
Um diese Moderationskarte zu schreiben, habe ich drei Jahre gebraucht, weil jeder Buchstabe ein Gemälde ist.
Und jetzt reden wir auch über das Thema.
Ich schreibe das nicht drei Jahre lang auf, damit Sie hier reinkommen und das Thema ändern. Also, die Frage ist, warum nicht die Schätze in der Pyramide nehmen? Die sind in der Nachwelt. Woher wissen wir das denn? Nach unserem Glauben sind die in der Nachwelt beim Ra. Moment, bei Ra? Ramses? Nein. Ramses ist unser König. Ja. Ra ist der Gott, einer der Gotter. Jupiter? Ne, ne? Da bin ich jetzt völlig. Anubis zum Beispiel. Ja, das ist der Totengott, glaube ich. Zum Beispiel. Und da muss man sich einkaufen, wenn man dann da liegt. Also vor allem, das Problem ist ja, egal wie viel Gold du deinem König mitgibst in die Nachwelt, das ist immer zu wenig, weil du lebst ja unendlich lange, du kannst ja in der Nachwelt nicht mehr sterben. Das ist so ein Startkapital, so ein Monopoly, was man am Anfang einem so gibt. Ach, du meinst, du machst dann da so einen Bubble-Tea-Shop auf in der Nachwelt und kannst dann so ein bisschen einkaufen. Ja, damit kannst du ja auch Geld leihen und so, gehst du zur Nachweltbank und dann kannst du ja auch theoretisch die Geld leihen für deinen Himmelspalast. Ich meine nur die Frage, also ich will es nur mal sagen, ob der jetzt tausend Gulden oder zehntausend Gulden hat, ist egal, weil er muss es aufteilen auf unendlich viel Zeit. Lass uns doch neun tausend Gulden da rausholen. Du meinst, weil es eh egal ist. Wir hungern hier, wir essen hier diese Krebse, was auch immer das sein soll. Und währenddessen neben uns, so, aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, das tut ja nicht an, Amun-Prinzip ist ja, die hatten den großen Schatz in der Totenkammer, aber dann haben die sich gedacht, ja was passiert denn, wenn da jemand einbricht, so ein Typ mit Hut und Peitsche vielleicht, in tausend Jahren, zum Beispiel. Was machen wir denn dann? Und dann haben die gesagt, ja, wir machen folgendes, wir machen eine kleine Schatzkammer vor die grosse Schatzkammer, dass wenn jemand einbricht und die kleine Schatzkammer sieht, denkt, ja, das ist die Schatzkammer, nimmt das aus und geht. Ehrlich gesagt, es ist brillant. Es ist brillant. Es ist brillant. Es ist absolut brillant. Idee, das auf viele verschiedene Probleme, die wir gerade haben, anwenden. Wie sind wir überhaupt darauf gekommen? Warte mal, das wäre doch jetzt geil. Wenn man sagt, okay, Verschwörungstheoretiker sind ein Problem. BRD, GmbH, Verfechter, Reichsbürger sind ein Problem. Ja. Jetzt bauen wir denen, weil es ja, die suchen ja quasi die Schatzkammer, die Wahrheit, jetzt mal metaphorisch gesehen. Genau. Jetzt bauen wir denen so eine Vorkammer. Lassen die die finden, damit die happy sind. Zum Beispiel, wir geben denen sowas wie, ah ja stimmt, ja, sorry, wir haben euch alle verarschen wollen, Personalausweis, ist wirklich Personalausweis bei ihr Personale. Ja, ihr habt uns überführt. Sorry, sorry, sorry, jetzt heißt es ab sofort Identitätskarte. So, und dann heißt es jetzt Identitätskarte, die sagen, wir haben gewonnen, okay, wir haben die BRD GmbH gestürzt, wir alle tun erschrocken und sagen,
ach ja, ist gestürzt, gestürzt, gestürzt und dann
machen wir noch so eine große Kampagne, ZDF,
ARD, jetzt nicht mehr Staatsmedien,
jetzt öffentlich rechtlich,
öffentlich finanziert, nicht mehr
Staatsmedien, sorry für die
Diktatur die letzten 50 Jahre.
Und dann gehen die aus ihrer Schatzkammer, aus der
kleinen Schatzkammer raus. Aber genau, genau so meinte ich das nämlich, mir ist eingefallen, wie wir darauf gekommen sind, nämlich, ob wir nicht Politiker sein könnten. Und ich glaube, ein Politiker mit kleinen öffentlichen Sünden ist besser als der ohne Sünden. Weil der mit kleinen öffentlichen Sünden, da kann sich jeder die Satire, kann sich den Mund aufreißen, aha, der hat damals irgendwie, der hat einen Kampffisch ertrinken lassen, der hat sich Kratzeis liefern lassen, der ist mit Boosted Board auf dem Boden gefallen, hingestürzt. Und da kann man sich drüber lustig machen, aber die Warnskandale können dadurch vielleicht versteckt werden, durchs Tutankhamun-Prinzip. Aber wo wir gerade bei Verschwörungstheorien sind, das Tolle, ich mag ja am liebsten die Verschwörungstheorien, für die sich so niemand interessiert und die auch egal sind. Also klar, so eine 9-11-Mondlandung, das sind geschichtsträchtige Ereignisse. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel eine Verschwörungstheorie, dass alles nur halb so groß ist. Das hattest du, glaube ich, mal erzählt. Das finde ich immer noch fantastisch. Das ist das Beste. Alles ist nur halb so groß. Die Verhältnisse sind weiterhin gleich, aber alles ist nur halb so groß. Jetzt kommen wir an einen Punkt, wo man auch nicht mehr widersprechen kann, was ich fantastisch finde. Die Idee ist, dass alle Länder nur halb so gross sind, wie man uns sagt. Sehr ungefährlich, diese Theorie auch. Das heißt, wenn da irgendwie steht, noch 60 Kilometer bis Kassel, sind es eigentlich 30 Kilometer. Was aber egal ist, weil du bist nur noch halb so gross. Aber die Regierung gaukelt dir vor, es seien 60 Kilometer. Und da stelle ich mir vor, angenommen diese Verschwörungstheorie stimmt tatsächlich. Es gibt eine riesige Verschwörungstheorie von Satelliten, von GPS-Herstellern, Navigationssystemen, die alles falsch anzeigen. Die stecken alle unter einem Hut und es wird irgendwie ein neuer Bundeskanzler gewählt. Und der erste Tag irgendwie, Bundesnachrichtendienst kommt, jemand schwarzer Anzug sagt, hier guten Tag, die Akten, alles ist nur halb so gross und wir belügen die Öffentlichkeit seit 200 Jahren, bitteschön, hier ist der, hier ist der, halb so, ein Ordner, von dem sie Dach, er wählt sich 40 cm hoch, weil der neue Kanzler wird sich doch auch denken, ja, ich werde doch jetzt nicht an die Öffentlichkeit gehen, Pressemitteilen und sagen, guten Tag, alles ist nur halb so gross, wir haben sie ja seit Jahrzehnten belogen. Oder er ist seltsamerweise sehr schockiert, macht eine Schublade auf und eine Knarre drin ist und ballert sich eine Kugel in den Kopf, weil er damit nicht klarkommt. Ich glaube, es gibt einfach so Probleme, die sind so peinlich und dumm, dass wenn du da das Fenster verpasst,
die öffentlich zu machen, werden
die nie öffentlich. Das kann sein, ja. Und ich glaube,
dass die meisten Verschwörungen, die tatsächlich existieren,
einfach nur existieren, weil
irgendjemand verpasst hat, im richtigen
Moment das zu
veröffentlichen. Und jetzt kannst du nicht mehr sagen,
übrigens seit 60 Jahren
ist unsere Flagge
eigentlich falsch rum.
Aber jetzt sind wir bei dem, wie ich es nenne, Nutella-Problem. Gerade waren wir noch bei der Tutel-Nich-Armon-Lösung. Jetzt sind wir beim Nutella-Problem. Du meinst nicht, dass man das Nutella-Problem mit der Tutel-Nich-Armon-Lösung lösen kann? Das weiß ich nicht, das können wir gleich noch hören. Lass mich mal kurz anfangen zu erklären, was das Nutella-Problem genau ist. Ist nämlich das kleine Fenster, das ist das Nutella-Fenster, das es gibt, wenn dir ein Frühstückspartner gegenüber sitzt und ein Nutella-Brot zum Beispiel, ein Toast konsumiert, der isst das Nutella-Brot, ein bisschen was bleibt am Rand hängen. Es gibt ein schmales Fenster, wo du ihm sagen kannst, ihr sagen kannst, Moment, du hast da was. An der Schnute. An der Schnute. Sagen wir, wie es ist, ganz unverblümt, du hast was an der Schnute. Sieht nicht schön aus. So, nach 20 Minuten wäre das unglaublich seltsam. Nach drei Stunden undenkbar, nach acht Stunden lang Zeit zusammenverbracht, ein Grund, diese Zusammenarbeit, dieses Zusammenleben zu beenden. Ja, nach dem Frühstück schaust du zwei Staffeln Friends und nach der achten Folge sagst du, ja du übrigens, du hast Nutella an der Schmitte. Ja, das geht nicht. Geht nicht. Das geht nicht. Das geht mit nichts im Gesicht oder mit, weiß ich nicht, manchmal hat man irgendwie so einen Popel noch irgendwo hängen und so. Das ist ganz menschlich, das passiert mal. Ja, obwohl der Popel kann ja jederzeit entstanden sein. Wohingegen beim Nutella, wenn es klar ist, dass es entstand am Frühstückstück. Daher kommt der Name, weil es genau den Zeitpunkt klar macht. Dankeschön. Das ist nämlich genau der Zeitpunkt und das ist ein schmales Fenster und da müssen wir alle auf Zack sein. Wir müssen auf Zack sein. Ich habe das Gefühl, manche Menschen sind nicht auf Zack, manche Menschen sind langsam. Könntest du natürlich nach acht Folgen
Friends sagen, oh, ich mache mir noch schnell
Nutella-Toast, willst du auch einen?
Ja, gut, jetzt geh. Und dann holst du
aus der Küche, weil du acht Folgen
lang dich nicht auf die Handlung konzentrieren konntest.
Und sie sagt, Schatz, nee,
wir hatten heute Morgen, nee, dankeschön, ich möchte nichts.
Und du sagst so, fang, dann isst du es
und dann fällst du so auf sie drauf.
Oder genau, du isst es und küsst sie. Du isst es, hast selber Nutella, küsst sie und sagst dann, oh, jetzt machen wir das mal weg. Moment mal, das ist aber schon ein bisschen angetrocknet. Wir müssen das beenden, wir müssen diese Beziehung beenden. Ich mache Schluss, das war. Das geht nämlich nicht anders, dann ist das wirklich, ohne Scheiß, man kommt da nicht so gut wieder raus.
Deswegen gibt ein schmales Fenster, das anzusprechen, und ich glaube, du hast vollkommen recht.
Es gibt ein paar Dinge, die einfach seltsam unausgesprochen sind.
Und vielleicht, jetzt verbinden wir das mit dem Tudemisch-Armen-Problem, gibt denen doch mal sowas, den Verschwörungstheoretikern.
Was Kleines.
Gibt denen was Kleines, was vergessen haben, gib denen so ein bisschen
Nutella an der Schnüss,
damit die ihre Klappe halten.
Und dann sind sie zufrieden und gehen in
normalen Tätigkeiten wieder nach. Das fände ich
nicht so schlecht. Ja, sowas
Uraltes von hundert Jahren. Wir haben damals
im Unabhängigkeitskrieg diese eine
Kriegserklärung, die haben
wir gefälscht. Die
kam eigentlich von uns. Und sorry. Das tut uns leid. Ja gut, du musst dir schon ein bisschen ein grösseres Stück Fleisch hinwerfen, glaube ich. Ach so. Das ist keine Schatzkammer, die du dir gegeben hast. Das ist so ein Kack-Nebentür- Raum, der leer ist. Ja, ja, ja, ich weiß, was du meinst. Als wir damals dieses Flugzeug verloren haben, das haben wir gar nicht verloren, das gab es nie. Das haben wir gar nicht gebaut.
Ich wüsste zu gern, wie das passiert ist. Ja, also wir haben so getan, als würde es abheben und dann...
Warum?
Weil wir mussten Geld einsparen und konnten uns das Flugzeug gar nicht leisten und haben dann gedacht, wir verbuchen das und bauen in Anführungszeichen dieses Flugzeug und haben dann gesagt, ja, das verschwindet dann halt irgendwo im Bermuda-Dreieck. Oh, das Bermuda-Dreieck übrigens, ganz witzige Story, alles was da verschwunden ist, gab es nie, sondern das haben wir immer versucht, ein bisschen Geld. Aber das Belmunder-Reihe gibt's. Ja, ja, ja, das beim Munderdreieck gibt es. Das war sehr schön da wahrscheinlich. Das ist wunderschön, sehr leer, tatsächlich, sehr leer. Ja, glaube ich, ehrlich gesagt. Und ja, also wie gesagt, die Nationalhymne, da sind so viele Grammatikfehler drin. Das ist mir aufgefallen. Wir konnten aber leider ab einem gewissen Punkt nicht mehr sagen, sorry, da hat Herr Brahms sich leider so komplett, aber auch komplett geirrt. Brahms hat ja auch geschrieben, okay. Das ist auch neu. Ach so, oh oh oh, ja, ja, ja, und der hat also der hat komplett einen Rotz abgeliefert, ich habe da noch drüber geguckt und so ein paar Sachen kundiert. Aber jetzt musst du aufpassen, dass die Schatzkammer nicht wie eine Art Köder funktioniert im Sinne von okay, wenn da so viel zu holen ist, dann will die richtige Schatzkammer. Auch da musst du die Dosis finden. Aber das ist auch so ein Ding. Ist diese tut-in-ich-Armut-Strategie, ist das eine gute Idee? Ich finde, das ist eine super Idee. Aber da werden noch damals zwei Pyramiden-Baumeister gesagt haben und einer hat gesagt, ja nein, wenn die Gold finden, auf dem Drittel des Wegs ins Kinderre... Aber das wissen diemessen. Angenommen wir tun so, als wäre die Pyramide doppelt so groß, dann würden die denken, sie sind schon in der Mitte, sind es aber gar nicht. Wenn wir draußen dran schreiben, 300 Meter Durchmesser und die gehen 150 Meter rein, denken, das ist die Mitte, das ist die Schatzkammer, dabei ist die eigentlich 600 Meter Durchmesser. Okay, ich finde das gut, eine gute Taktik, ehrlich gesagt. Kann aber auch das Gegenteil sein. Es kann exakt das Gegenteil, es kann auch unlockend wirken, das weiß ich nicht genau. Wir haben wenig Präzedenzfälle mit Pyramiden, es gibt wenig Leute, mit denen wir mal kurz quatschen können, die Azteken sind haltstausend Jahren ausgeschaut. Auch Pyramiden, ne? Völker hatten unabhängig voneinander auf der Welt Pyramiden hingepflanzt. Ja. Alle aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen. Es gab aber auch runde Gebäude. Will ich nicht sagen. Das muss ich nicht. Nee, will ich jetzt nicht sagen. Ich möchte jetzt keine neue Verschwörungstheorie aufstellen. Aber auch Türme hoch. Oder lang, ganz langgezogenes Gebäude. Ich habe neuerdings sehr doll Angst vor dem West-Nil-Fieber, dem West-Nil-Virus. Das ist ein Virus, der gerade in den USA auch ausgebreitet ist. Tipp, lebt nicht im Westen des Nils. Dankeschön, aber leider Gottes ist diese komische Moskito-Art, Mückenart, jetzt auch hier in Europa angekommen. Und mein Problem ist, ja, weiß ich nicht, viele Fragen. Uber. Mein Problem ist, ich bin ja Aids-resistent. Und genau diese Mutation wird jetzt mein Kryptonit. Das heißt, es ist ein bisschen so wie so eine langweilige Version von Achilles, der quasi unzerstörbar ist, aber hat seine Ferse und die ist tödlich plötzlich. Ein bisschen so ist es jetzt mit mir und dieser Aids-Resistenz, weil genau diese CCR5-Mutation, die ich habe, sorgt dafür, dass ich super anfällig bin, dieses Vestnil-Virus zu bekommen. Okay. Heißt, und seitdem habe ich unglaubliche Angst vor Mücken. Ich habe heute Morgen eine Mücke in meiner Wohnung gesehen und ich habe mich noch nie so schreien gehört. Ich bin aufgesprungen, weil ich wirklich Angst davor jetzt habe. Ich habe immer auch keinen Mücken-Expert. Ich weiß nicht, wie die unterschiedlich voneinander aussehen und vor welcher Mücke ich jetzt Angst haben muss. Aber wo wir gerade beim Nil waren, dachte ich, habe ich direkt direkt zusammengezuckt. Wahnsinn, aber vom Westen des Nils bis zum ... Der Osten des Nils, easy. Da kann ich nackt rumlaufen, durch den Nil spazieren. Denkt mich, nehmt mich. Übrigens, ich glaube, genau in der Talk-Show, wo der eine Sitzler sagt, gehen wir eigentlich komisch, sitzt auch der andere Ägypter, der immer sagt, wir sind zu abhängig vom Nil.
Wir sind zu, Leute, ich sag's immer wieder. Immer wieder derselbe Hottake. Es gibt verschiedene Hottakes in dieser ägyptischen Talkshow, beim ägyptischen Lanz.
Der Nil steigt jedes Jahr und wenn wir weiter unseren Flussgott, nein, aber wenn der nicht steigt, dann sind wir alle am Arsch! Die Talkshows waren damals anders. Es war wilder, es war anders, es war einfach eine andere Kultur. Aber die Idee ist jetzt, du hast so eine Art Ganzkörperanzug an aus dicken Polyester, wo die Mücke nicht durchstechen kann. Du hast mich jetzt gar nicht gefragt, warum ich so gekleidet bin heute. Und ihr fragt euch bestimmt, warum ihr mich so dumm hört die ganze Zeit. Das liegt daran, weil ich in so einem Ganzkörper-Polyesteranzug bin, der bei der Wärme, ich sag mal so, schwierig ist. Ja, das ist das Problem im Sommer. Ich glaube, deswegen kommen Mücken im Sommer raus, weil die wissen, oh, jetzt kommen die kurzen Hosen, die T-Shirts. Jam, jam, jam, jam, jam, jetzt komme ich, wohingegen im Sommer alle in ihrem Seesternenanzug sind und irgendwie eingekleidet. Dicke Anoraks. Jetzt kommen die im Sommer raus. Dünne Anoraks. Ich habe Angst jetzt vor Mücken. Ich weiß nicht, ich wurde gestochen, hier ist ein Stich, den sieht man gut, der ist doch so dick angeschwollen, da habe ich jetzt auch direkt gesagt, gut, das war es mit mir, weil das ist glaube ich auch kein Virus, mit dem zu spaßen ist. Was ist das Westnilfieber, was passiert, was sind die Symptome? Tot. Inzintot. Quasi sofort tot. Wie, sofort tot. Unheilbar tot. Das geht doch nicht. Ich glaube, Fieber ist ein Symptom, aber ich will mich nicht so weit aus dem Fenster lehnen. Man fängt an, komisch zu gehen. Man fängt an. Man ist magisch angezogen von eckigen, grossen Gebäuden. Ich liebe diese Gebäude. Ich male, meine Handschrift wird merkwürdig und langsam. Ich fange an, komische Kopfbeleckungen zu tragen und balsamiere. Okay, gut, ich kann ja mal für dich darauf achten in den nächsten Wochen, ob mir dieses Verhalten auffällt bei dir, ob da Farbe steht. Ganz ehrlich, man gerade das so zusammenfasst, Ägypter sind schon all in gegangen, ne?
All in. Die sind total spezifisch.
Ja. Die haben gesagt, lass uns alles
speziell machen.
Lass uns anders gehen, lass uns
komische Kopfbedingungen tragen, immer
oberkörperfrei sein, aus irgendeinem Grund,
unsere Mode ist far away,
vergesst Jeans, wir tragen
nichts. Weg mit den Jeans, weg damit.
Oder so Lederländenschurz, viel mit Gold, wir sind unglaublich reich, wir bauen komische Gebäude, bei denen war alles einmal anders. Und das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das und diese Ausstellung, wir sind im Natural History Museum in New York, haben wir das ja alles gesehen, mit diesen ganzen grossen Steinfiguren, die da alle hingewuchtet wurden, mit grossen... Niemand weiß wie. Niemand weiß wie, grosse Hubschrauber oder was auch immer wurden da hingewuchtet und sind jetzt da, ist grossartig. Und Streitwagen, alles mit Streitwagen, weil man noch nicht reiten konnte. Wie? Reiten, das weiss man, denkt man, man nicht reiten musste, lange erst entwickelt werden, dass Leute auf Pferden reiten können. Aber kennt man ja, man kommt
nicht drauf, manchmal.
Vielleicht ist die Menschheit auch mal irgendwann
einfach nicht drauf gekommen. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie
so ein Sudoku, wo du einfach nicht drauf kommst.
Du weißt einfach nicht, es ist, ach die drei.
Wie bei mir mit 60 mal
10,2. Ich bin ja nicht blöd,
die Menschheit ist ja nicht doof, aber manchmal
kommt man nicht drauf. Ja, vielen Dank an alle, die uns
die Lösung geschickt haben. Ja, vielen Dank. Wow, wow, danke. Als ob wir nicht in der Lage wären, das rauszufinden, wenn wir es rausfinden wollen. So viele selbstgefällige Drecksnachrichten auch im Sinne von, ich habe mich selber gefragt, wie ich so schnell darauf gekommen bin, deswegen habt ihr hier meinen Trick. Bitteschön, nee, die gucke ich mir jetzt extra nicht an, wegen so einer selbstgefälligen Kacknachricht. Ja, aber ich glaube, so ging es Ägyptern auch, die vor dem Pd saßen und dachten, da ist was, da liegt was. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich... Dann haben sie Pferde an zwei Achsen gebunden und dann sind so Pferde so wie ein Rad, haben sie es benutzt und dachten, und einer stand davor und dachte fast. Fast, fast. Lass uns zwei Menschen vor ein Pferd spannen und das Pferd ziehen. Nein, nein, nein, wir ziehen das Pferd ganz schnell übers Schlachtfeld. Haben das Pferd hinten auf den Streitwagen gepackt und so drei Dröpf-Sklaven vorne hingepackt und die standen da vorne und dachten. Ja, wir kommen näher, wir kommen näher, wir kommen näher. Und Zügel ist ja ein riesiges Problem, Zügel sind ein riesiges Problem. Da musst du erst mal drauf kommen, dass du dem Pferd so ein Kaugummi gibst und da irgendwie so Zügel dran sind und es dadurch steuerst, weil bis dahin hat das Pferd ja keine Ahnung, wo du bist. Das Pferd sieht den Reiter ja nicht und kann nicht mit ihm reden. Und woher soll das Pferd auch nur im Ansatz wissen, was der Reiter von dem Pferd will? Aber wir stecken doch unsere Haare ins Pferd rein. Ja, das kann man natürlich machen, oder?
Damit man diese Verbindung hat. So eine lange Kolonne, dass der Reiter vor dir falschrum sitzt und mit dem Pferd kommuniziert, über sich Kontakt. Und dann gab es ja natürlich, irgendwann später konnten dann Leute reiten und dann gab es berittene Bogenschützen, die dann Pfeile schießen konnten, aber es war nicht klar, wie sollen die die Zügel halten und ihren Bogen abfeuern. Und was die gemacht haben ist, da ist jemand nebenher geritten, ein zweiter Reiter. Also ein Sidecar. Ein Sidecar und hat die Zügel gehalten. Auf dem Esel. War das ein kleineres Pferd neben dem großen? Ja, okay. Und der hat die Zügel gehalten von dem, der mit dem Bogen geschossen hat. Das heißt, du brauchst für einen Bogenschützen zwei. Und irgendwann hat man überlegt, man gibt dem auch einen Bogenschützenbogen, damit der auch schießen kann. Und du brauchst den dritten Reiter daneben. Mit dem Pony. Ja, aber auch das, so da brauchst du zwei Pferde für einen Bogenschützen, bis du dich jetzt alles entwickelt hast. Wir denken immer, oh, Auto, krass, wow, Entwicklung und so. Dieses ganze Tierzeug ist genauso, muss sich genauso entwickeln. Ich glaube, der Trend könnte aber wieder zum Tier gehen, ehrlich gesagt. Tiere so groß zu züchten, dass man die Autos benutzt. Ja, ja, ja. Die Fähne sind ja fantastische Autos. Ja, aber dann so ein Stau und dann stehen die rum und einer will nicht mehr und dann bockt der und dann hast du so ADH irgendwie ADHC. ADHC kommt dann durch die Ecke, ist ja natürlich schwierig. Also jeder, der Stronghold schon mal gespielt hat, weiß aber, wie wichtig die Idee war, Briten im Bogenschützen einzusetzen. Absolut, absolut. Die sind schon schnell und gefährlich. Ja, schnell und gefährlich ist auch der Zorn Gottes, wenn er auf uns herniederschlägt. Hast du die Woche was gemerkt von dem Zorn Gottes? Ich glaube, das lag an dem Shitstorm von unserem Giftfestival, das um sich geschlagen ist. Ich glaube, Gott und Gifts nimmt sich sehr ernst. Von daher... Das Giftfestival, ja, das... Willst du noch ein Wort dazu sagen? Ist erst mal auf Eis gelegt, weil... Ja, das würde jetzt viele stockieren. es klingt aber auch, ehrlich gesagt, schön sommerlich frisch. Ehrlich gesagt, ich würde auch gern auf Eis gelegt werden, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Also die Veranstalter, das ganze Komitee ist entsetzt, wie uns das passieren konnte, beim aller allerersten Gift Festival, wurde nominiert, sagen wir wie es ist, ein MP4. Ja. Und wir sind kein MP4-Festival. Wir sind das Gegenteil, würde ich fast sogar sagen. Wir sind ein Gift-Festival, da haben wir keinen Ton, wir haben Frames, die eckig aneinander geraten sind und nicht in einem Videoformat zusammenhängen. Emil hat uns hinters Licht geführt, er hat MP4 geschickt und wir haben es einfach nominiert. Ja, aber ich möchte nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie ein großer Shitstorm auf Emil niederprasselt. Dieser Shitstorm gebührt uns. Wir haben richtig, richtig verbockt. Wir haben unsere Verantwortung missbraucht. Ja, und da müssen jetzt auch Konsequenzen gezogen werden. Also ja, der Shitstorm von euch war komplett berechtigt. Vielen Dank an die zahlreichen, unzähligen Nachrichten, die uns erreicht haben, wie es denn sein kann, nach dem Motto, ob du ein Beispiel benutzt.
Und deswegen, es tut uns leid und ja, wir sagen bis jetzt, es werden Konsequenzen gezogen und wir müssen gucken, ob und inwieweit das Festival fortgesetzt werden kann. Wir tun alles, damit uns nicht die höheren Mächte verurteilen. Wir haben ein weiteres Thema in unserem so guten alten neuen neuen Reime Lachen mit der Bibel. Lachen mit der Bibel, wir haben ja letzte Woche schon ordentlich abgelacht. Lachen mit der Bibel heißt unsere neue Reihe? Ja, Lachen mit der Bibel. Und Hannes hat uns ein weiteres Beispiel geschickt, wie die Bibel tatsächlich lustig ist. Die Bibel war ja ein Unterhaltungsroman. War das der gleiche, da davor auch schon die... Nee, tatsächlich nicht. Da kommen alle Leute, jeder hat einen Gag, so einen klassischen Party-Gag, den sie erzählen aus der Bibel. Und Egon beschreibt eine Szene, wo... Der Hintergrund ist ganz kurz, wir suchen nach altertümlichen Gags. Nicht nur Bibel, aber ich finde auch spannend, wie hat sich der Humor, wie ist der Comedy-Podcast, wie hat sich Humor in der Zeit verändert? Ja, genau. Oder wo gibt es Szenen, die vielleicht lustig gemeint sein können? Die wir heute aber gar nicht mal als Gag verstehen. Genau, wo man einfach, wo Bibelforscher davor stehen und sagen, was soll das denn? Und es basiert alles auf einem hebräischen Wortspiel. Stellt sich raus, willst du es einfach nicht verstehen? Also, in R.I., ich weiß nicht genau, was R.I. für eine Psalmbezeichnung ist, Hannes, du überschätzt mich massiv. Rino. Rino 3, 12-31 wird das Volk Israel mal wieder von einem anderen König unterjocht. Die schreien zu J.H.W. J.H.W. ist der Gott. J.H.W.H. Jehova. Jehova oder Jach, weil man meistens nicht ganz genau, aber einfach drei Buchstaben. J.H.W.H. Es sind drei gewollt, es waren mal vier, glaube ich. Ja, kann auch sein, glaube ich, aber im Laufe der Zeit ging das unter. Und sendet den Richter Ihud zu diesem Fremdkönig, der Eglon heißt. Warte, warte, ganz kurz. Okay. Zu viele bugierte Namen. Also, J. H. H. schickt Ihud zu Ihop. Zu Eglon. Eglon und sein Bruder Deglon und Degomir. Also, Ihud soll Eglon Tribut zahlen und wird zu ihm vorgelassen. Es ist wie ein Prequel von Herr der Ringe, das einfach super lame ist.
Ja, also jetzt wird es verrückt. Da Ehud Linkshänder ist, wird sein Dolch bei der Kontrolle vor dem Einlass zum König nicht gefunden, da er rechts an dessen Gürtel ist und nicht wie gewohnt links.
Stimmt. Und jetzt sage ich.
Kennt jeder bei der Fussball-Einlasskontrolle, wenn man nach Waffen abges... beim Flughafen. Weiß ja jeder, dass man nur bei Rechtssendern immer links guckt. Fucking Bullshit. Und das klingt für mich, als ob Matthäus oder wer auch immer den Teil geschrieben hat... Der Rino. Rino, einer der... Ringo, einer der unbekannten Evangelisten, dessen... Pfeimer nicht gelegen war. Ringo, der unbedeutendste Beatle und der unbedeutendste Evangelist. Einfach, das ist so eine klassische Plothole-Korrektur. Und er steht vor dem König und er deucht ihn! Ja, aber warum wurde er nicht auf Waffen untersucht, bevor er zum König gelassen wurde? Oh fuck. Oh shit. Er ist so ein bisschen so eine Note, die man bekommen könnte vom Verlag. Übrigens nicht ganz so wild, aber eigentlich ist es unrealistisch, dass er einen Dolch noch hat. Und dann sagt er, ja, der ist halt Linkshänder und die gucken alle nur immer so auf die rechte Hüfte. Aber ich verstehe schon, es klingt erstmal nach einer guten Idee. Und dann stellt man sich das genau vor und denkt, was ein grober Quatsch. Ja, es ist Bullshit, es ist Bullshit. Also, Ehud wird also bewaffnet zu Eglon vorgelassen und er erstellt... Warum habe ich von keinem dieser Namen jemals gehört eigentlich? Weil das eine dieser weirden Stellen in der Bibel ist, die nie gepredigt werden, die nie verfilmt wurden. Aber ich will mal, wie ein Pfarrer von Eglon und Iglu erzählt und Käpt'n Eglon, das ist doch besser albern. Also, Ehud wird bewaffnet zu Eglon vorgelassen und er ersticht Eglon mit diesem Dolch und versteckt sich danach im Klo. Im Klo? Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie das damals in altertümlicher Zeit aussah. Das Personal sucht den König und denkt dann, dass er auf dem Klo sei, da Ehud sich dort versteckt hat. Das Personal will den König nicht beim grossen Geschäft stören, sie gehen also weg und Ehud entkommt schliesslich. Was ist sonst noch witzig an dieser Geschichte? Also anscheinend war bis jetzt schon was witzig mit dieser ganzen Klo-Versteck-Geschichte, ulkig auf jeden Fall. Es fliegt für mich so ein bisschen wie einfach so ein lamer Thriller irgendwie. Ich glaube, so ein bisschen Spannung mit aufbauen, so er versteckt sich vor den Wachen, die finden ihn nicht genau. Vor allem, ich dachte jetzt, ich dachte, die Geschichte nimmt eine andere Wendung, dass er zum neuen König wird, der nur vom Klo aus regiert. Weil wenn die Wachen denken, der König ist im Klo, kann der ja sagen, ja, ich bin der König. Mehr Geld für die Armen. Aber sie haben doch gerade noch anders gesprochen. Ja, hat mich verschluckt, hat mir was eingefangen. Das Westnilfieber. Reißt meine Gruft ab mit dem ganzen Gold und verteilt sie an die Armen. Also, was ist noch witzig? Es wird deutlich erwähnt, dass der Dolch schwer durch Eglons Wanst durchsucht, weil er so fett ist. Also es wird explizit erwähnt, dass der König so dick ist, dass er schwer zu erstechen ist. Eine random Notiz, die eigentlich nicht zum ernsten Tonus des Richterbuches passt. Aha, R-I ist Richterbuch, nicht Ringo. Ja, Bibelhumor ist aber auch speziell, Fäkalhumor und Bodyshaming hat damals wohl als Humor noch gereicht. Anders als heute. Da muss man sich ja mal RTL angucken, um zu wissen, dass es heute ganz anders ist. Aber Hannes kann es nicht lassen, hier auch nochmal den Bibelhumor zu kritisieren, führt hier ein scharfes Schwert gegen die Comedians in der Bibel. Also das ist die witzige Geschichte von Ehud und Eglon. Aber ganz kurz, unsere Frage ist ja auch, was wurde damals als Witz verstanden? Also hat man damals diese Geschichte gelesen und hat sich beömmelt? Das ist meine Frage. Weiß ich nicht, aber er wurde ja trotzdem erstochen. Witzig wäre es ja gewesen, wenn er so dick ist, dass er gar nicht erstochen werden kann und er dann sagt, na gut, dann muss ich ihn halt vergiften. Und dann vergiftet er die Torte und dann keine Ahnung so. Ist diese Wahlgeschichte, ich meine auch nicht lustige Geschichten, sondern lustige Gags, aber ist diese Wahlgeschichte mit Jona, der vom Wal verschluckt wird, ist das auch eine Bibelgeschichte? Ja, ne? Glaub ich, kann sein, ja, weiß ich nicht. Woher kennen die ersten zwei, haben nicht mal eine Wahl, woher wissen die von der Existenz von Wahlen? Eine Wahl kann man ja sehen ab und zu, oder, in so witzigen Videos mit Gifs. Weil die müssen ja aufs offene Meer gefahren sein. Naja, okay, aber das ist jetzt auch lustig gemeint, oder? Dass es von einem Wahlen, dass Jona von einem Wal verschluckt wurde? Oder bin ich gerade irgendwo bei einem Disney? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Aber so auf jeden Fall, es gibt Comedy in der Bibel, man muss sie nur finden. Und ja, vielen Dank für diese Einsendung in unserer neuen Kategorie. Bibel kam auch lustig. Lachen mit der Bibel. Letzte Woche habe ich eine kleine Hausaufgabe aufgeben. Ja, genau. Die muss ich verschieben nochmal. Ich habe meine Nachbarin, die ist Übersetzerin, gefragt, wie man folgendes Szenario übersetzen würde. Jack Sparrow ist kurz...
Genau, Flutzerkriebig, Teil 5, soll hingerichtet werden mit einer Guillotine
und sagt dann den Satz, ich habe ihn letztens sogar falsch zitiert,
ich zitiere ihn jetzt nochmal richtig, er sagt dann, wenn er raufgeführt wird zum Schafott,
sagt er, how about a good old stoning, I'd kill to be stoned right now.
Wow, das wäre vielleicht gut gewesen, wenn ich das vorher gewusst hätte, Aber ich habe meine Nachbarin übersetzt englische Literatur. Und ich habe sie gefragt, ich habe mir diese Situation erzählt, den Satz, den ich von ihr mitbekommen habe, war ja I'd rather be stoned. Was aber ja ähnlich funktioniert. Und sie sagt, ja, man erschiesst sich eigentlich am liebsten, wenn man das liest als Übersetzerin, weil man da dann drei Nächte nicht schlafen kann, überlegt, wie man das übersetzen kann. Das ist die schlimmste Form von Wortwitz. Absolut, das Wort Stoned als High ist natürlich absolut schrecklich. Aber sie sagt im Buch immer noch einfacher, weil man natürlich Dinge weglassen könnte, man könnte ihm eine Geste geben und so weiter. Aber bei einem Film zum Beispiel, wo man im schlimmsten Fall sogar noch Lippensynchron texten muss, heißt, du musst dir einen Witz ausdenken, der schon nicht gut funktioniert und dann muss der ja noch auf die Lippenbewegung von Sonny Depp passen. Furchtbar. Aber sie hat gesagt, sie will nachdenken. Ich habe sie gestern erst getroffen, habe mit ihr gesprochen. Sie möchte nachdenken und möchte mir einen Übersetzungsvorschlag machen. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich werde heute auflösen, was die Filmübersetzer in der deutschen Fassung übersetzt haben. Aber ich habe ihr auch dazu aufgerufen, dass unsere klugen, klugen Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer selber Ideen einschicken könnten, wie man diese Stelle übersetzen könnte. Also die Situation ist die, Jack Sparrow soll hingerichtet werden und sagt dann, ich wäre jetzt lieber stoned, gesteinigt, high gewesen, Gag, den die Leute verstehen. Und zwar hat uns geschrieben, unsere Hörerin Limo hat uns, wie ich finde, eine fantastische Idee geschrieben, und zwar schreibt sie, Jack Sparrow könnte sagen, ich würde mich lieber abschießen.
Es geht ja um alternative Hinrichtungsmethoden.
Super. Und er sagt,
er sagt ja im Satz auch, how about a good old stoning, I'd kill to be stoned
right now. Könnte man sagen, ja, wie wär's denn mit einer
Erschiessung, ich würde mich jetzt gerne abschießen.
Ich würde mich lieber abschießen.
Ja, ich würde mich jetzt lieber abschießen.
Ich glaube, das würde man sogar halbwegs verstehen.
Und finde ich eine absolut fantastische Lösung.
Super gemacht von Limo.
Du bekommst von Florentin
Vielen Dank. Ich würde mich jetzt lieber abschliessen. Ich glaube, das würde man sogar halbwegs verstehen und finde ich eine absolut fantastische Lösung. Super gemacht von Limo. Du bekommst von Florentin ein Fünfer. Du kriegst einen Fünfer zugeschickt, schick mir deine Adresse und ich schicke dir einen Fünfer nach Hause. Andere gute Idee von Simon, der hat auch ein bisschen out of the box gedacht mit anderen Hinrichtungsmethoden und der hat geschrieben, ich würde lieber qualmen. Also wie wärst du mit einem Scheiterhaufen dann? Ich würde lieber qualmen.
Aber jetzt muss man nur sagen, verlässt man ein bisschen die Figur Jack Sparrow zu einem sehr lyrischen Menschen.
Ja, genau. Ich wollte jetzt lieber qualmen.
Das Problem ist ja, dass das Wort, das man eigentlich bräuchte mit Stone, da gibt es ja auch kein einziges deutsches Wort dafür. Das heißt, du müsstest eigentlich ein Wort benutzen, das ganz klar auf Marihuana-Konsum hindeutet. Und da hast du ja natürlich das deutsche Wort Kiffen, was du gut benutzen kannst, was aber unmöglich irgendwo einzubauen ist, was keine doppelte Bedeutung hat und nichts und auch keine gute Synonyme hat.
Ich habe jetzt mal bei Synonyme, die ihr geguckt, Synonyme für Kiffen, Smoken, Rauchen, Haschen,
habe ich mir nie gehört, und Qualmen. Also Simon ist da auf einer richtigen Spur, er hat ein gutes Synonym gefunden für Qualmen.
Ich habe mir auch überlegt, in welche Richtung ich gehen würde, weil ich bin noch am Joint geblieben,
habe aber auch keine gute Lösung gefunden. Ich dachte aber vielleicht auch, weil er hat ja diese Doppelstruktur, how about the good old stoning, I'd kill to be stoned right now, hätte ich gedacht, wie wäre es denn mit einem Scheiterhaufen, ich würde mir jetzt gerne einen anzünden. Ja, auch nicht ideal. Ganz ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, man sollte nicht beim Stone bleiben. Ich glaube auch nicht, die Steinigung ist, glaube ich, ein Steinweg. Weil ich finde es aber auch im Englischen keinen wahnsinnig guten Gag, weil man ihn noch nie, weil man im ganzen Futurimik-Universum noch nicht einmal Joint gesehen hat, man hat Jack Sparrow noch nie high gesehen, Drogen haben keine Rolle gespielt, ausser Rum, von daher finde ich, ich würde mich lieber abschießen, tatsächlich fast besser als das Original. Ich finde diesen Stoned, ich finde, das ist das letzte, woran man sich hängen sollte. Ich finde, man sollte vor allem, und da kann man auch als Übersetzer massgeblich nochmal alles umändern. Absolut, weil es passt sogar zur Szene, weil er wird nämlich zur Guillotine gebracht und davor wird einer der Soldaten sagt ihm, ah, Herr Sparrow, was hätten Sie denn gerne, ein Firing Squad oder gehängt? Also es werden schon verschiedene Formen der Hinrichtung aufgezählt. Super. Also kann man wunderbar hier auch
sagen mit dem Scheiterhaufen, ich weiß nicht mit
ich würde lieber qualmen, ich würde mir einen anzünden,
ob das, ob die Leute
das verstehen, schwer zu sagen, auf jeden
Fall. Aber man kann auch in ganz andere Hinrichtungsmethoden
gehen. Ich fand natürlich auch dein
in Rum ertränken oder irgendwie
sowas, ertränken ist natürlich leider keine
gängige Hinrichtungsart,
aber irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall Das ist schwierig. Dieses Stoning-Stone-Stone-Stock-Stock-Stock-Stock-Stock-Stock also ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, aber es gibt diese Art von Szenen, die lustig sind oder lustig sein sollen, aber keine Gags beinhalten. Also Gags für mich definiert als, ich schreibe ihn auf ein Blatt Papier, schiebe ihn dir rüber, du liest ihn und du sagst, ah, lustig. Ich sage, ich sage, sehr trocken, mit leblosen Augen. Ein in sich geschlossener Witz, der funktioniert. Und es gibt aber oft in Szenen, und das ist so eine Szene, fluchtig über fünf grauenvoller Film, grauenvolle Szene, er soll hingerichtet werden und der Gag, der übergeordnete Gag ist so ein bisschen, dass Jack Sparrow halt überhaupt keine Angst hat vorm Tod und es halt alles total laissez fernimmt. Und der Soldat sagt ihm, ah, wir haben eine neue Hinrichtungsmethode für City, die Guillotine, und er sagt, ah, eine Guillotine, das klingt französisch, ich mag Franzosen, die haben die Mayonnaise erfunden. Und man denkt sich immer, das sind keine Gags, das ist, natürlich ist die Idee, dass er das so locker nimmt, lustig, aber da kann man doch einfach Gags reinschreiben. Und das ist so diese unangenehme Art von Szene. Aber man versteht genau, woher es kommt, weil es ist so wie Fanfiction von Jack Sparrow. Genau. Weil Jack Sparrow war natürlich im ersten Teil auch irgendwie, oh, eine Hochzeit, Drinks für alle! War halt genau so, und ich verstehe schon, noch nie in Singapur gewesen. Also diese kleinen Sprüche, die man halt irgendwie augenzwinkernd hinnimmt und sich drüber amüsiert. Ja, es ist so diese Attitüde, der es aber an Substanz fehlt. Also die Attitüde ist richtig, die Art, wie das dargestellt wird, ist richtig, aber es fehlen halt die Gags. Ja, es ist wie von Foto-Karibik-1 irgendwie was abgucken, ohne genau hinzusehen. Weil bei Foto-Karibik-1 hat jeder Spruch auch Sinn. Genau. Und selbst, ich meine, selbst sowas wie noch nie in Singapur gewesen, während er ihr quasi metaphorisch gesehen die Hülle aufschneidet und sie sich befreien kann, ist ja alles, kein Beispiel für einen Gag, aber ein Beispiel dafür, dass in diesem Film, Flugzeuger Karibik 1, hat alles eine doppelte Bedeutung, alles ist total gelayert und dass er ist ja derjenige, der als Pirat ihr das biedere Leben aufschneidet und sie kann ins neue Leben rüpfen und es ist fantastisch. Ja, das ist ist großartig. Und so arbeitet Food of Karibik und eins und die anderen Filme leider nicht mehr. Ja, und das ist ein kleines Beispiel, das überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Das sind oft so Szenen, wo dann die lustige Musik anfängt. So diese Lust und du merkst schon direkt, oh, das wird nichts, das führt zu nichts, weil Gags brauchen nicht die lustige Musik, du brauchst für die normalen Gags nicht so eine Musik, weil es für die sich steht und ganz, ganz schrecklich auf jeden Fall. Und jetzt sage ich euch, wie es tatsächlich in der deutschen Fassung übersetzt wurde. Und man muss da aber mit dem Hinterkopf behalten, wie der Satz im Original lautet. Er heißt nämlich I'd kill to be stoned right now. Und die deutsche Fassung macht daraus, wie wäre es jetzt mit einer Steinigung, ich würde sterben für eine Steinigung. Also der eigentliche Gag wurde komplett ignoriert. Oh, aber nicht so schlecht. Das Stoned-Wortspiel wurde komplett ignoriert, aber ich glaube, man hat sich hier fokussiert auf die Situation, ich würde sterben für eine Steinigung, was im Original schon angelegt ist, I'd kill to be stoned right now, es ist ein Doppelgag eigentlich. Oh, es ist ein Doppelgag im Original. Er sagt bei seiner Hinrichtung, I'd kill to, was im Deutschen ja eigentlich lustiger ist, mit ich würde sterben für.
Ich würde sterben für eine Stattdigung, finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Es ist gar nicht so schlecht. Ich finde den super. Anstatt zu sagen, I'd kill to, was ja nicht lustig ist, weil er, dass er tötet, ist ja nicht so lustig, als wenn er jetzt sterben würde bei seiner eigenen Hinrichtung. Ich find's charaktertreuer, weil für mich ist er auch ...
Er macht viele Wortwitze und ist auch mit diesem ganzen Palais-Gedöns, er ist halt irgendwie, er stützt sich auf Wörter und so und weiß gut, mit Leuten umzugehen, kann sich aus jeder Situation herausreden, das ist so ein bisschen sein Skill. Und dann finde ich das hier einen Witz, der quasi sich komplett auf den Wortwitzteil fokussiert, anders als dieser blöde Joint-Ding, was für mich auch nicht so charakternah ist, finde ich das gar nicht, ich finde das richtig gut. Es ist halt die Frage, warum es überhaupt um Steinigung geht, warum das überhaupt einfach, also es geht danach noch weiter mit auch die Steinigung, die involviert das Publikum mehr, ist auch was für die Leute, also diese Art von lustig in Anführungszeichen reden ohne Gags kommen, die geht dann leider noch schrecklich lang weiter. Aber ich finde es gar nicht so schlecht. Es ist natürlich, man konzentriert sich auf einen anderen Satzteil, zu sagen, ich würde sterben für eine Steinigung. Ob es ein Lacher war, weiß ich nicht genau in den Kinosälen, aber so wurde es auf jeden Fall übersetzt, diese Szene mit Jack Sparrow. Ich bin gespannt, was deine Nachbarin sagt zu diesem Thema. Ganz ehrlich,
ich bin ja bei der Futur-Reprik 1
kam ja sehr früh in die Kinos.
Da habe ich auf jeden Fall auch noch
Filme auf Deutsch geschaut.
Und ich bin auf jeden Fall mit der Synchronstimme
von Johnny Depp
total geliebt.
Und ehrlich gesagt, was
die Synchronstimme macht,
ist fantastisch. Und die hat ja auch irgendwann aufgehört, mitumachen. Ich glaube, ab Teil vier gibt es die nicht mehr.
Also ich habe das heute nochmal nachgeguckt, Original und Übersetzung, und beide Szenen sind absolut grauenvoll. Es ist fast erstaunlich, wie unglaublich scheissegal Johnny Depp dieser Film ist und wie er sich null Mühe gibt, in keiner Situation. Es ist wirklich, vor allem, ich denke mir, also es ist nochmal einerseits schade, Filme zu sehen, die schlecht sind, aber mir tut es immer besonders weh, Filme zu sehen mit einem schlechten Drehbuch, einer schlechten Performance in einer grandiosen Kulisse. Mit coolen Kostümen, mit coolen Kulissen, alles cool beleuchtet, dieses ganze Navy-Zeug mit den Schiffen und das ist halt echt ein echtes Schiff. Und dann, du merkst genau, der Schauspieler gibt sich keine Mühe, der Drehbuchautor hat sich keine Mühe gegeben. Und das ist so respektlos gegenüber den Leuten, die da einfach jahrelang dieses Zeug zusammenzimmern. Nee, das stimmt nicht, die kommen danach. Das heißt, die hätten dann schon im Prozess sagen können, nee, ich habe keinen Bock drauf. Aber das ist immer so maximal unangenehm.
Ja, weil du hast halt ein Kontrastmittel, plötzlich wirkt halt etwas fremd, weil es zu sehr hervorsticht.
Es ist so viel Aufwand, weißt du, wenn irgendein Studentenfilm lustig sein würde und dich lustig singt, ja gut, das war kein Aufwand, das war ein Nachmittag. Aber da, wo hunderte Leute jahrelang dran arbeiten und du baust dieses riesige Schafott auf und du hast 200 Extras da mit dieser Hinrichtungsszene, nur für deinen I'd Rather Be Stoned Gag. Für den haben tausend Leute gearbeitet an dem Tag. Aber das tut wirklich weh. Und mir ist es immer so unangenehm, wenn Schauspieler oder so, der Moment, wo zum ersten Mal Leute dann die Texte, die man geschrieben hat, vorlesen und so und so konkret wird, ist immer maximal unangenehm, weil ich denke, jetzt bist du aus Berlin oder so hergeflogen worden, um das jetzt zu lesen und plötzlich kriegt alles, was man so nebenbei hingeschrieben hat. Klar, manche Sätze steckt mehr Arbeit als in anderen Sätzen und so, aber plötzlich kriegt alles so wahnsinnig viel Gewicht und so und Leute arbeiten dann an den einzelnen Sätzen, das ist total gruselig.
Und ich finde, da muss man auch teilweise demütig sein und sich der Verantwortung bewusst sein. Auch ganz unangenehm jetzt mit Justice League, mit diesem Snyder's Cut, der jetzt rauskam, der ursprüngliche Snyder's Cut, der davor für die Kinoversion noch mal von Joss Whedon wurden ja Szenen noch mal umgefilmt, also neu gefilmt, mit Gags eingebaut. Und wenn du dann immer siehst, wie die ursprüngliche Szene war, was Zack Snyder damit aussagen wollte, und wie Joss Whedon dann einfach was komplett anderes macht und einfach schlechte Gags reinbaut. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagt, wir haben so einen geilen Gag, lass uns die Szene noch mal drehen, lass uns Amy Adams noch mal anrufen, lass uns noch mal 10 Millionen Dollar ausgeben, einfach um das zu machen, weil der Gag so geil ist. Aber nein, es wird dadurch noch schlechter, noch ein schlechter Gag und es ist so unangenehm. Ja, das ist wirklich unangenehm. Boah, richtig unangenehm. Also ja, es ist... Aber interessant. Also ich finde es total so, dass wir diese Rubrik haben, die Humorlupe. Wirklich? Ist das die Humorlupe? Das ist die Humorlupe. Wir nehmen Humor nochmal genau unter die Lupe. Ist das was anderes als Lachen mit der Bibel? Ja, es ist aber so eine Unterkategorie.
Okay.
Lachen mit der Bibel ist eine Unterkategorie von Humor unter der Lupe.
Ja, okay.
Wir sind immer noch das Podcast-Ufo, oder?
Ja, wir sind eine Unterkategorie von der Rubrik Humor unter der Lupe.
Alles klar.
Ist das Podcast-Ufo eine Unterrubrik?
Wie viele Rubriken müssen wir jetzt abmoderieren?
Drei noch. Jetzt haben wir drei Klammern aufgemacht.
Jetzt musst du noch mal, wie viele Klammern machen wir jetzt zu? Immer wenn ich mit dir rede, habe ich das Gefühl, wir haben fünf Klammern auf, weil wir beide zu unfokussiert in alle Richtungen denken und schießen. Unfokussiert ganz anders als die Humorlupe. Das war's für diese Woche von der Humorlupe Upe Upe Upe Upe Upe. Jetzt sind wir wieder zum Glück im ernsten Teil des Podcasts. Mich treibt eine Frage um. Mich treibt eine Frage total um. Und zwar, wenn ich bei Lieferando online Trinkgeld gebe, wissen die Leute, dass ich ihnen Trinkgeld gegeben habe? Ja, das ist die Frage. Ich habe immer, ich versuche meinen, und das ist kein einfacher Blick, ich versuche, wenn ich diese Tüte entgegennehme, immer meinen, ich habe euch Online-Trinkgeld-Blick aufzusetzen. Wird hier noch Trinkgeld erwartet? Natürlich. Das ist für mich der Hauptgrund, nicht Online-Trinkgeld zu geben, weil ich mir denke, nein, nein, nein, im Leben nicht, die kassieren das selber ein, da kriegt der Fahrer von nichts oder er weiss es nicht. Das stimmt nicht, weil das kann ich mir nicht glauben, weil zu viel wurde da recherchiert und nachgefragt, ob die es wirklich bekommen und so. Ich glaube, das kann sich die Verando nicht erlauben. Da wurde nachgefragt und nicht nur einmal. Und ich glaube das nicht, ich glaube, das bekommt er an. Aber vielleicht bin ich da auch naiv und dusselig und vielleicht sollte noch mal jemand genau die Trinkgeldlupe anmoderieren. Ja, aber es ist trotzdem, selbst wenn sie es bekommen, wahnsinnig unangenehm. Ich traue denen überhaupt nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist es so ein Ding, dass man das Trinkgeld dann denen vom Gehalt abzieht. Oder irgend so ein perfider Scheiß, weil man das dann genau abrechnen kann. Wohingegen, wenn du denen einfach zwei Euro in die Hand drückst, kriegt es ja niemand mit. Und dann ist es aber ich am direktesten. Deswegen, Online-Trinkgeld mache ich nicht. Ich habe einen dicken Stapel zwei Euro-Stücke neben meiner Tür liegen. Wo hast du den aber her? Wo akkumulierst du denn die zwei Euro-Stücke? Immer wenn ich einkaufen gehe und alle zwei Euro-Stücke, die ich bekomme, sammle ich, stapel ich auf dem Stapel, damit ich immer Trinkgeld habe und immer was abgeben kann. Und ich bin da sehr zufrieden damit. Online-Trinkgeld traue ich nicht. Ich traue dem nicht. Bei mir gab es halt die Phase, wo ich kein Kleingeld hatte, wo ich gerade auch so zu Corona-Hochzeiten, wo man halt vor allem dann versucht hat, mit Karte zu zahlen und kein Kleingeld mehr zu haben, hatte ich dann kein Kleingeld mehr und dann habe ich angefangen, Online-Trinkgeld zu geben.
Und ich habe mich jedes Mal wahnsinnig schlecht gefühlt und immer einer hat, der hat hat gesagt, Trinkgeld kannst du ruhig auf den Rucksack legen.
Aber das fand ich super. Finde ich auch gut. Weil dann kann man sagen, ich habe es bereits online gegeben. Und dann kriegt man aber den Blick. Man kriegt den Blick. Dann krieg ich den Blick. Ich denke, es ist aber auch nicht so schlimm, wenn sie es nicht wissen, weil klar, die
Chance, ich habe noch nie, glaube ich, einen Fahrer zweimal gehabt, einmal, glaube ich,
heisst also die Chance, dass dir jemand in die Suppe spuckt, ist nicht vorhanden quasi, weil Leute denken immer noch, laufen immer noch ins offene Messer und denken, sie kriegen Trinkgeld, haben es online bekommen, das heißt, und das ist ja das Ende der Kette, heisst, die sehen ja nicht, ah, da gibt kein Trinkgeld, noch während sie mir in die Suppe spucken können. Das heißt, sie könnten ihr maximal ins Gesicht spucken, an der Tür. Sie können maximal mit ihrer Faust immer in Gesicht schlagen. Das heißt, es gibt immer, aber ich fühle mich einfach schlecht dabei. Und deswegen, aber vielleicht seid ihr die Ferando-Fahrerin und könnt uns mal sagen, wie soll man es machen. Was ist für euch die eingenehmste Art, wie soll der Kunde sich an der Tür verhalten, wie wollt ihr es? Aber es ist schon merkwürdig, wie willkürlich Trinkgeld verteilt ist. Also manche Berufe gibt man Trinkgeld, manche nicht. Und es gibt kein klares System dahinter. Und ich fände gut, wenn eine Pressemitteilung käme von einer Berufsgruppe, die sagt, wir wollen aber jetzt auch Trinkgeld, man gibt uns jetzt Trinkgeld. So die Kassierer, Supermarktkassierer sagen, übrigens, ab jetzt wollen wir auch Trinkgeld haben. Man kann an der Kasse sagen, 28,30 und du gibst 30 auch und sagst, stimmt so. Ab jetzt machen wir das so. Geht das, kann eine Branche das einfach durchboxen, zu sagen, wir wollen jetzt auch Trinkgeld haben. Weil warum denn nicht? Warum kriegt ein Kälter Trinkgeld und ein Supermarktkassierer denn nicht?
Ja, und dann jetzt manchmal ist man auch irgendwie, wird man komisch angucken, wenn man Trinkgeld gibt. Also normalerweise ist ja eine tolle Geste und man kriegt dafür, man kriegt was zurück, man kriegt ein großes Dankeschön. Aber manchmal merkt man an der Grösse des Dankeschöns, dass es unangemessen war, Trinkgeld zu geben. Ich war neulich irgendwo abends eingeladen und habe Wein mitgebracht.
Und dann war ich ganz klassisch in so einem ganz klassischen Weinladen, so einem ganz kleiner Weinladen, habe dann drei Flaschen gekauft und habe Trinkgeld gegeben. Und die Geste war, wow, okay. Okay, Sie sind der erste Mensch, seit 120 Jahren, die es im Weinladen gibt. Und dann dachte ich mir, ah fuck, gut, war nicht nötig. Und dann ist mir aber eingefallen, dass in dem gleichen Laden habe ich das schon mal gemacht, habe vergessen, dass da habe ich eine ähnliche Reaktion bekommen, die ist mir dann wieder eingefallen in dem Moment. Und damals war es so, da habe ich die Summe falsch verstanden und habe dann zu viel Trinkgeld angesagt. Dann war die Geste und dann kamen ganz viele Reaktionen auf mich, prasselten auf mich ein und ich wollte kurz mal sagen, du musst es kurz anhalten. Ganz kurz sozialer Stopp, Spielstopp. In so einem rundenbasierten Rollenspiel, du drückst auf Stopp und ich muss jetzt erstmal meine Antworten auswählen. Erstmal, oder wenn man wirklich in so einem DSA-artigen Rollenspiel wählt, muss man kurz sagen, nee, sorry, ganz kurz, was mache ich jetzt? Worauf darf ich würfeln? Darf ich auf Menschenkenntnis würfeln? Weil es kam zurück, es kam die Reaktion zurück, hier gibt man kein Trinkgeld. Ja. Ah, dann kam zurück, du hast die Summe falsch verstanden, du hast zu viel Trinkgeld gesagt, ich habe 52 Euro gesagt und du hast 60 stimmt so, weil du nicht 58 oder so verstanden hast. Ja. So, heisst, und dann kam das zurück, und dann ist immer das Unangenehmste, wenn man zu viel Trinkgeld ansagt, ich war neulich mit einer Freundin irgendwo in einem Café mal wieder, und sie hat auch die Summe falsch verstanden, hat dann zu viel Trinkgeld angesagt, dann gibt die Kellnerin einem sowas zurück wie nee, nee, es sind nur 12 Euro. Ach so, ja, dann mach 14. Und dann ist es immer so unangenehm, weil jetzt ist es wie nichts mehr wert. Jetzt ist es nicht mehr, wenn man sagt, mach 12 Euro, ja, 14 stimmt, so, dann kriegt man, ah, dankeschön, und es ist schön, es ist eine gute Geste. Es ist auf Mathematik reduziert, es ist keine Geste mehr, es ist nur noch, du hast dich verrechnet. Du hast dich verrechnet. Die Zahlen waren falsch. Und dann ist das über dem gute Geste. Und wenn man dann sagt, 20 stimmt so, nee, ich habe 10,20 gesagt, ach so, 12, dann ist es immer so, weil jetzt hat sie schon irgendwie mit einer anderen Summe gespielt im Kopf und dann ist es plötzlich 12, ist es unangenehm. Es ist unangenehm, aber kleiner Tipp, weil eigentlich ist es ja, was der Weinladenverkäufer oder Verkäuferin gemacht hat, ja eigentlich genau falsch, wenn dir jemand Trinkgeld anbietet, so was, was, was zu reagieren.
Zu lachen. Weil eigentlich, wenn du in dem Moment eiskalt bleibst und sagst Danke und dem Kunden vermittelst, das ist normal, dann schaffst du es, dass deine Branche in diesen Trinkgeldkreis aufsteigt. Wenn genug Leute das völlig souveränes Trinkgeld annehmen und vielleicht der Kunde, der hinter dir steht, sieht, oh, der hat Trinker gegeben, das ist eine normale Interaktion, jetzt gebe ich auch Trinkgeld. Und irgendwann fangen im ganzen Land an, Kunden Trinkgeld zu geben und wenn dann alle Verkäuferinnen und Verkäufer souverän bleiben und sagen Danke, wird irgendwann die Branche der Weinverkäuferinnen und Verkäufer aufgehoben in die Trinkgeldbene und geht dann nie wieder raus. Weil wenn das mal normal ist, trinket es tatsächlich auch. Mich macht wahnsinnig, dass niemand weiß, dass es mit mir angefangen hat. Ich meine, ich will kein großes Lob oder so. Ich will nur, dass Leute wissen, dass mit mir angefangen hat. Eigentlich müssen jetzt alle Weinverkäufer gegen dich demonstrieren, weil du die Entwicklung aufgehalten hast. Du hast ja, nee, eigentlich müssen sie sich bei dem Verkäufer beschweren, dass der nicht souverän genug reagiert hat und den eigentlich rausschmeissen aus dem Club der Weintrinker, der Winery Society. Der normalen Menschen, der Normies. Eigentlich schon. Es ist wirklich interessant. Vor allem in den USA habe ich immer ein großes Problem, weil ich weiß um das Klischee, dass Europäer und Deutsche zu wenig Trinkgeld geben in den USA, weil eine andere Trinkgeldkultur herrscht, also überkompensiere ich unglaublich, auch an Ständen, wo mir alle sagen, hier musst du kein Trinken geben. Und ich vermisse mich immer wieder der größte Depp in den USA, aber ich vermisse es auch. Aber wärst du gern in so einer Society, der Wine Drinker Society oder irgendeiner Gruppierung, weil du bist ja jetzt Segelfahrer, gibt es da nicht auch irgendwie so die Nordwind-Buben oder so, irgendwie so eine Vereinigung, wo du wirklich dabei bist. Eine Bruderschaft meinst du? Ja, sowas in der Richtung, weil ich habe letztens mich beschäftigt mit der, ich glaube Star Wars World oder so heißt es, im Disney World gibt es ja einen Star Wars Bereich und als die angekündigt wurde, dieser Theme ParkPark-Bereich, sah man auf den Werbebildern immer Droiden rumfahren, also kleine Roboter, die selbst gesteuert sind. Genau, die selber gesteuert sind und mit denen die Zuschauer interagieren können, wie diese Dubai-Polizei-Roboter, die die Leute ins Wasser werfen und so. No problem detected. Keep the part. Genau, da ist auch einer, es war gerade mal ein, I notice you are wet. In England gab es mal einen Roboter, der ist testweise rumgefahren, und dann ist irgendeine Frau, wo etwas ganz Schlimmes passiert, da ist sie da hingelaufen, völlig in Panik, weil sie beklaut wurde oder sowas, und der Robot hat nur ganz, dann stand in dem Artikel, he whistled an intergalactic tune and said, keep the park clean, please. Aber ich finde, ich musste so lachen, laut lachen über den Satz, he kept whistling this intergalactic tune, weil, man kann es nicht besser beschreiben. Warum ist ein Roboter automatisch intergalaktisch? Ein Roboter, der auf der Erde gebaut wurde, ist automatisch in der intergalactic Society. An Intergalactic Tune, gefiffen, ist alles so fantastisch. He kept whistling. Keep the park clean. Hilfe, Hilfe, ich werde ausgeraubt. Keep the park clean. Aber da und dann gab es überall diese Bilder von diesen selbstständigen Druiden, die rumgefahren sind und mit den Zuschauern und mit den Besuchern interagieren. Und als dann aber Star Wars World aufgemacht hat, war kein einziger Roboter da.
Und alle waren enttäuscht, weil sie sich dachten, das war doch so cool, wie diese Roboter, diese R2D2s fahren da durch die Gegend.
Und die ganzen Bauer des Parks denken so, aber wir haben fucking Millennium-Falken, alle hängen sich daran auf, dass kein Droiden rum.
Ja, aber wir wollen diese kleinen Maus, diese Mausroboter.
Und der Grund, warum es keine Roboter gab, war, dass sich Disney World nicht mit der Puppeteering Society einigen konnte. Oh yes. Und da dachte ich, als ich das Wort Puppeteering Association gehört habe, dachte ich mir, hell fucking yes. Einfach, die haben so viel Einfluss, die Society of Puppeteers, also die Puppenspielervereinigung, die da nicht eingreifen konnten, dass sie sagen können, wir können nichts, Disney ist machtlos gegen die Puppeteering Society. Ich finde es super, aber dass die Droide Rechte haben, finde ich toll. Ja, absolut, und dass sie sich dafür einsetzen und dass sie wirklich eine bessere Gewerkschaft haben als wahrscheinlich die Disney World Paris Mitarbeiter. Das ist das Coolste an der Star Wars Celebration, wo ich eigentlich fast jedes Jahr war, als sie stattgefunden hat, war, dass dann immer Erz-Vodizos und kleine Druiden rumgefahren sind, diese Mausroboter. Man hat nie gesehen, von wem sie ferngesteuert wurden, die sind einfach rumgefahren und du konntest mit denen interagieren. Von so einem Typen, der eine Cola in der Hand hat, der in der Nähe steht und einfach mit seiner Fernsteuern. Der seine Cola knibbelt. Es gibt ja, wenn du in der Schule bist, immer diese Berufsorientierungslehrgänge, wo dir Fragen gestellt werden und dann kannst du so ein bisschen gucken, welcher Beruf könnte für dich in Frage kommen. Und ich finde das Beste, was ich je gehört habe, dass ein Schüler da bekommen hat, hat mir eine Freundin erzählt, die meinte, eine Freundin von ihr damals in der Schule hat bekommen, Puppenspielerin. Aber weil so, ja, Polizistin, Offizierin, Architektin und du, Lena, Puppenspielerin. Aber ja, Polizistin,
Offizierin, Architektin
und du, Lena, Puppenspielerin.
Perfekter Sketch.
Es ist der perfekte Sketch, es ist die Poate.
Nichts gegen Puppenspieler,
großartiger Berufsstand, aber es ist schon
merkwürdig. Aber es ist unglaublich spezifisch.
Und jetzt dachte ich mir, mein
größter Kritikpunkt an diesen Berufsinformationszentren war, finde ich, immer diese Generic-Berufe.
Weil bei allen bei uns war es immer Ingenieurwesen, Wirtschaftsingenieurwesen, war es bei allen, bei mir auch.
Es kommt halt auch darauf an, wie die Fragen sind. Arbeiten Sie gerne mit Zähnen?
Nein.
Arbeiten Sie gerne mit Zähnen? Nein. Arbeiten Sie gerne mit Nasen?
Nein. Arbeiten Sie gerne mit Füssen? Ja. Ah, okay. Und da muss man noch so ein paar Fragen noch abhandeln, obwohl du schon lange weißt, was du ihm empfiehlst. Also wir haben jetzt das Ergebnis für sie und ja, Lukas, du könntest wahrscheinlich gut arbeiten als Päde... Nee, Pade... Pädeatrischer Arzt. Wie schaffst du den hier? Pädeontolo... Nee, wie heißen die? Padeontologe. Padeontologe? Nein. Nee, Paleontologe ist Dinosaurier, Pädagoge ist mit Bildung, Pediatrician, Pädiatrationskämpfer. Pädiatratrat, man, ich habe mir noch ein Zeh gebrochen, ich war doch da. Beim Pedersarzt? Beim Pedersarzt? Weißt du, beim Pedersarzt? Pädiatriker, nein. Pädiatriations. Pädrik. Wir wünschen euch jedenfalls eine fantastische Woche, kommt gut durch die Woche, geht raus in die Sonne, geniesst den Start des Sommers.
Florian und ich, wir sitzen nächste Woche noch hier
und haben dann die Antwort für euch.
Palamander.
Macht's gut.
Stille Woche, haut rein.
Macht's gut. Woooo! It's a worse prediction. Seid's vom Standard? Willkommen im Ruhrgebiet. Echt statt inszeniert. Jede Ecke anders, jede Story echt.
Späti-Romantik an der Trinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Halde.
Klingt anders? Ist es auch.
Dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt.
Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta.
Mein.Ruhrgebiet.